sabrina carpenter is the queen of glow
ups
she's so talented that the most
challenging part of filming her new
movie work it was trying to be
bad at dancing but the road to stardom
isn't an easy one
especially when you end up with big
disney channel expectations
thankfully sabrina's used to the drama
and has tons of talented friends
supporting her
from being a little red-headed guest
star in austin and ally to how she's
trying to inspire women to have it all
today
here's how sabrina has grown up in the
spotlight and what big plans are next on
her to-do list
let's pretend that i'm actually 15 so
this doesn't feel as embarrassing
it seems like only yesterday we were
watching little lucy gluckman stun
on austin and ally and now sabrina has
grown into a full-blown disney channel
icon
she started performing when she was only
11 but now sabrina carpenter is 21 years
old and ready to put her disney days
behind her
even though she'll always have love for
her disney channel roots
and we'll always be up for a girl meets
world marathon
but being a disney star comes with a lot
of expectations and sabrina is still
trying as an adult to finally shake them
off
so let's have a look at what her
career's been like so far
sabrina grew up in pennsylvania dancing
five or six times a week
she was always a performer and an
incredibly hard worker
landing her first disney channel role in
2011 on
austin and alley as lucy gluckman in the
episode
moon weeks and mentors just a year later
she landed a voice credit on phineas and
ferb
and then by 2014 it was official sabrina
would star as maya hart in a major
disney channel spin-off
girl meets world remember how we all
freaked out because boy meets world was
finally getting a female-centric redo
well sabrina was busy being both excited
and terrified by her first real shot in
the spotlight
it was actually hannah montana that
inspired sabrina to chase her dreams
and give her the confidence to become a
multi-talented performer
in an interview with in the nose gibson
johns she talked about how she was only
six years old and watching the pilot
episode
and that's when her dreams really
started to become clear like hannah
and most of us obsessed with the show
sabrina wanted to sing
dance and act she also daydreamed about
wearing all of hannah and miley's crazy
colorful costumes
which is something we definitely have in
common sabrina went on to say that she
gets jealous when she watches people act
in movies or perform
because she wants to be the one on the
stage she really was born for the
spotlight
but even though she knew she was great
sabrina had no idea what was coming her
way
she even got to star in her own disney
channel original movie
adventures in babysitting joining the
ranks of other dcom stars like demi
lovato and selena gomez but as she got
older sabrina decided it was finally
time to put the disney days behind her
though she did tell teen vogue that she
enjoyed coming into herself while
playing a character that was also
growing up
plus we got to see her grow up alongside
us imagine how different our childhoods
would have been without sabrina on our
tvs
nowadays sabrina refers to disney as the
d word
she doesn't enjoy re-watching her old
shows especially girl meets world but
only because she doesn't always feel
like it reflects who she is as a person
now
plus it's strange to see your younger
more awkward self dressed in crazy
outfits and doing eccentric things on
screen
would you really want to watch your
middle school self try to tackle fame
and do televised interviews
yeah didn't think so now sabrina's moved
on to another major television and film
company that's giving her more freedom
to be who she wants to be
you might have heard of this little old
streaming service called netflix
first she appeared as harper crayman in
tallgirl but with workit
she finally has her starring role in a
netflix movie
in the film which sabrina describes as a
new generation's version of step
up sabrina plays quinn an overachiever
with a 4.0 gpa
and some huge college aspirations when
duke university says her
extracurriculars suck
she ends up forming her own dance troupe
alongside liza koshy and jordan
fisher it's a huge opportunity for
sabrina who gets to cement herself as a
netflix star
and work alongside some of the most
famous young faces today
plus we get to see another dancing movie
and there are never
too many right dancing was the biggest
challenge for sabrina while filming but
not
in the way you might think it was
challenging for her to have to be bad at
dancing
she told cosmo that dancing badly might
be harder than dancing well
we don't know about you but being bad at
dancing would have come completely
naturally to us thankfully sabrina was
up for the challenge and cites channing
tatum as one of her celeb crushes
that helped inspire her to be in a
dancing movie channing tatum is also one
of
our celeb crushes but we probably won't
be getting any invitations from netflix
to star in a dance movie
oh well now that she's made her journey
from disney to netflix
sabrina is eyeing the next big thing she
has four pop albums out
and even a few dramas like the short
history of the long road
and the hate you give on her resume plus
she was a producer on work it
making her a star who can sing act dance
and
work behind the scenes a true quadruple
threat
but are you even surprised however being
21 and growing up famous
isn't easy so sabrina has also had to
weather a few storms to get as far as
she has
she spoke with elle recently about
embracing being an adult and her fears
she explained that she used to be
fearless
at auditions when she was young and now
auditioning and getting rejected is
becoming harder and harder but she's
opening up about these feelings so that
young women everywhere know that
self-doubt is completely normal in the
past few years she's learned that being
a disney channel star
isn't all sunshine and rainbows she not
only had to deal with huge fame at a
young age but she also lost her good
friend
cameron boyce in 2019 while 2020 marked
the passing of her grandfather
now she's struggling with being not busy
enough while studios figure out what's
next
in an uncertain world but doing promo
for work it in quarantine has been her
saving grace
especially when it involves her awesome
friends like liza koshy
sabrina also turns to jordan fisher and
joey king for support
that's definitely a group of friends
we'd love to hang out with
she told teen vogue that supporting your
friends is a gift
we couldn't agree more sabrina while
sabrina would rather focus on
friendships the media has always hounded
her about relationships
just imagine how embarrassing and
dramatic trying to date was in high
school
and multiply that times a thousand it
all started when sabrina was linked to
her girl meets world co-star
corey foglemanis though she put those
rumors to rest by saying their love was
completely platonic
she's also been linked to her tall girl
co-star griffin gluck
and riverdale star casey cott who
starred in her why music video
but since her split from good luck
charlie star bradley stephen perry in
2015
she's mostly been single and living her
very best life
so what's next for the rising star well
work it may be all fun and games sabrina
wants to take on the serious stuff too
the stuff that comments on the way that
society works and that really inspires
change
like the short history of the long road
and the hate you give
reflecting on haley her hate you give
character now
sabrina told teen vogue that she's proud
to play a character that can be a mirror
for some people
as harsh as that may seem sabrina's not
afraid to take on the tough roles and we
all know that sometimes
you gotta see the bad to really
recognize the good that's out there
and to make serious changes that'll make
the world a better place
as a first-time producer on workit
sabrina is now thinking about how she
wants to keep
exploring the behind-the-scenes creative
process of creating movies and
television
right before we all got stuck in
quarantine she was starring in mean
girls on broadway as katie herron she
only got to perform two nights but she
hopes that as soon as things go back to
normal she can continue her broadway
dreams
and if they cast a musical mean girls
movie she'd be our first choice to star
so from a small red-headed aspiring
performer to a confident blonde
bombshell
sabrina carpenter has definitely done a
good job of growing up
in the spotlight she's gorgeous healthy
and happy
on the inside and the outside but she
knows that being a star is always work
and she's willing to put in the hours
with her amazing friends and fans
cheering her on
what do you think the next decade of her
life will look like how does it feel
watching sabrina carpenter blow up
right before our eyes let us know your
favorite rules from the work it stars
career in the comments
don't forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to the things for more
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time